Hey there, smartless fans and listeners. It's me, comedian, actor, wizard, Rory Scoville, and I'm busting into your ears right now to tell you about a new podcast that I hope you'll check out. It's called Crimeless. Every week, journalist Josh Dean and myself dive into a new story from the stupider side of the true crime world. Here is our trailer, and if it sounds like some of you'd like, just search for and follow Crimless wherever you get your podcasts. Have you ever listened to crime shows and found yourself with more questions than answers?
And what is this? How is that not a story we all know? What is this? Where is that? Why is it wet? Then boy, do we have a podcast for you. Is it a crime to cut someone's hair without their permission? And what if that person is a cat?
Is it even safe to snort human remains? What is the dumbest way to steal a quarter million dollars? Who catfish is a city? Is this even a crime? Honestly, it feels more like a high-level prank. than a crime. Introducing Crimeless,
a new show from the law-abiding geniuses at smartless media, campside media, and big money players. Join me, Roy Scoble, comedian and actor,
and me, Josh Dean, investigative journalist on our new weekly podcast that celebrates the amazing creativity of the world's
dumbest criminals. It has everything you could ever want in a show. Promiscuous primates. There are thousands of angry, horny monkeys.
Advice from the Great Beyond. I've realized you can't just out loud before the tarot card reading just go, will I ever have a threesome? We should ask a deeper questions, I think, right? Oh, I'm sorry, Josh. Am I going to have a threesome, not a deep question for you? Incredible voice acting? These guys were doing stuff that you can't even imagine with refrigerators.
Well, these cats have such a different struggle. And of course, plenty of stupid crime. If you can fake your own death and still live in the same town, and all you did was change your name, you are either an incredible actor or you live in the dumbest town. I've got to assume there are some obvious textural and color differences
between human ashes and cocaine. I gotta say outside of the double murder, kind of a fun guy. It was an attempted double murder, to be fair. Plus game segments. I can't believe it's the hardest trivia game on the poop episode. Every week, a new crime that asks the question, wait, what?
Turns on this show, folks. You cannot guess where Josh is going to take us. You don't. That's why they tune in, Rory. It's the mystery of it all. Crimeless, coming soon from smartless media, campside media, and big money players. We have great, would it, if at the end of season one,
you turned into like a master criminal. That's how the season should end. You and I should have to pull off a crime. Open your free Eyeheart Radio app Search Crimeless And listen now There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.